we're looking at potentially going from
seven days a year with a heat index of
105 here in miami-dade to close to three
months a year by mid-century
miami is the 44th most populous city in
the u.s and a global tourist magnet for
its beautiful beaches culture and
nightlife but the city has obvious
vulnerabilities like its exposure to
hurricanes dangerous
biggest threat is the storm surge as
well as some other concerns that are
gaining precedence
such as the effects of heat and sea
level rise
you can watch a hurricane advance on
your community on your iphone you really
can't see the rise of the sea but you
know it's happening and you know that in
the future it's going to accelerate
we're having increasing temperatures
both due to climate change
and to urban development patterns sea
level rise itself makes specific actions
like storm surge from a hurricane or
high tides much worse each year the
official statistics on heat related
mortalities are very low the epa reports
a little over 700 annually however
through many different research studies
on what they look at as excess deaths
during times of extreme heat the
predictions are much higher and
nationwide we're looking at over 8 000
to over 12 000 a year this is the number
one killer of any weather-related
disaster more than floods hurricanes
more than fires tornadoes populations
that are more vulnerable to heat can be
young children older adults pregnant
women they're more sensitive to the
temperatures people with pre-existing
conditions like heart and lung
conditions or on certain medications
there are also populations that are just
more exposed to heat and those could be
outdoor workers people who are what we
call air conditioning insecure and then
additionally those that are on house the
homeless population are more exposed
miami's problems of course are not
exclusive and cities everywhere are
starting to take action our region
unfortunately reported more than 300
people who died from heat exposure last
summer so we are not meeting that
livability expectation for everyone
we're working on reducing heat through
cooler pavements more pervious surfaces
and maintaining and enhancing our tree
canopy on managing heat we're working on
training disaster volunteers and
emergency medical technicians and
healthcare practitioners just to better
understand what are the signs of heat
related illnesses how do we respond
we're also working on a public education
campaign but the trees that go in the
ground this year are going to be five to
six feet tall we have to be looking five
to ten years down the road before those
trees are providing meaningful shade to
people on the sidewalks which is why we
also need to be thinking about other
strategies like reflective surfaces and
things we can do to keep people safe
this summer like having cooling centers
we have large
public services that we're responsible
for the airport the seaport the
transportation system supplying drinking
water so these facilities are relied
upon by our citizens by our visitors by
industries here to be operational all
the time on the ban a new crisis
emerging in texas we saw that a real
tragedy a couple winters ago in texas
with the winter storm and if something
like that were to happen in a large
american city in in the summer
particularly in the sun belt where it's
already very hot and we take away that
critical lifeline of air conditioning
the public health effects could be quite
serious air conditioning is the number
one user of energy in your home and that
cost is getting cost prohibited for
certain populations another area that
we're working on is increasing funding
and financing assistance to lower income
homeowners and renters whether think
about how much energy people can save on
their air conditioning bill when we add
that up across the region with 4.5
million people that's a lot of potential
savings when we're thinking about
avoided emergency department visits uh
overnight hospitalizations or even heat
associated deaths in some cases the
return on investment that's possible can
be in the billions with a b
even with promising returns hefty price
tags for infrastructure for any
municipality can be prohibitive the cost
of an action however is becoming more
obvious with each emerging crisis you're
rolling the dice if we don't prepare
then you've got to try to recover short
and long term for that and while you're
doing that your economy is going to be
battered
climate modeling studies suggest that
with significant action we could wind up
with a phoenix of the future that's
cooler than the phoenix we have today
even as global warming continues if we
have widespread deployment of some of
those cooling technologies we feel
pretty good about our approach and we're
really focused on implementation on
projects that provide greater protection
to our citizens based on science i'm
definitely optimistic for the outlook of
miami-dade county it has shown itself
time and time again through history to
be incredibly resilient to big shocks
and come back stronger every single time